l'Ukraine et la Russie ont donc procédé
à un échange de prisonniers militaire le
plus important depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine fin février on va tout
de suite partir à carqui-ves retrouver
Gulliver crack notre correspondant
Gulliver bonjour que sait-on exactement
des modalités de cet échange
alors d'abord ce qu'il convient de
souligner c'est qu'il y a 215
prisonniers Ukrainiens qui ont été
libérés dans le cadre de cet échange
contre seulement 55 que l'Ukraine a
libéré et a rendu au russe mais parmi
ces 55 il y
achouk politicien prorus ukrainien et
olicarque et proche de Vladimir Poutine
alors il faut croire que cela en dit
long sur la valeur qu'avec
les Russes pour Vladimir Poutine mais
très honnêtement c'est quelque chose qui
laisse beaucoup d'analystes un peu
perplexe puisque la Russie a cédé ses
combattants les combattants d'azosta qui
était considéré comme des prisonniers
vraiment de valeur pour la Russie alors
où vont-ils ils vont en Turquie c'est un
échange qui a été la Turquie a joué le
rôle de médiateur et il s'agit de qu'on
appelle l'extraction ce qui veut dire
qu'ils vont rester en Turquie jusqu'à la
fin de la guerre mais selon la
présidence turque dans des conditions
confortables et où leurs proches vont
pouvoir leur rendre visite alors c'est
clairement une très grande joie pour les
familles et les proches de ces
prisonniers libérés plus de
très positivement pour deux raisons
d'abord les défenseurs d'azophtales sont
vraiment considérés comme des héros en
Ukraine pour leur lutte acharnée pour
empêcher les la Russie de prendre le
contrôle de la ville stratégique de
Mario Paul il y a des graffitis sur les
murs de presque toutes les villes du
crâne célébrons le héroïsme de ces
défenseurs un grand nombre de son membre
du bâtiment Azov qui a des origines dans
l'extrême droite mais qui n'est
absolument pas perçu en Ukraine
aujourd'hui comme un bataillon d'extrême
droite alors c'est vraiment des héros
qui ont été libérés c'est une fierté
pour pour le pays et un grand
soulagement même s'il convient de
souligner que on est loin d'avoir obtenu
la libération de tout les défenseurs
d'Azov stalle ils étaient au nombre de
2000 on met quand ils se sont rendus en
captivité rust donc il y a encore des
centaines qui restent en captivité et on
ignore leur sort et puis deuxièmement
c'est un moment significatif pour
l'Ukraine